>> THEY COME IN HOT.
SHO JOHANSON.
TOMASINO.
WHAT A STOP BY CAMPBELL.
A CROSS ON THAT ON THE AND
TOMASINO HAS THIS PUSH RIGHT TO
THE INSIDE OF THE POST ANDATTHE.
ENGVALL SHOOTS.
KASE RUNNING A THREE-GAMEE HIM .
JEANNOT IS 84.
WHEN THE PUCK GOES ACROSS TO
TOMASINO.
THAT'S IT.
WE'VE GOT THREE GOOD LOOKS IN
THE FIRST EIGHT-AND-A-HALFE ICEE
SURE THAT THOSE CHANCES ON THE
RUSH DON'T HAPPEN AS
REMEMBER WHEN THE SCHEDULE WAS
BACK AFTER HIS FIGHT WITH
McCARRON..
REBOUND!
SCORES!
CHIP IT FROM IN TIGHT.
CROSSBAR POST AND STRAIGHT DOWNS
STANDING AROUND, THEY'RE LOOKING
HOLL WITH IT.'T KNOW, DID IT GO
BUNTING. KASE.
ENGVALL. FOR ANOTHER CHIP
NASHVILLE ZONE.
FORECHECK.D FOR
YOU SEE
HERE'S EARLIER ON.
HIM BACK ON THE ICE.
>> PASS
KASE.
PUSHES EKHOLM OFF THE PUCK AND
HE PROTECTS IT
KNOCKED AWAY BY NYLANDER. ROMAN.
TOMASINO.
AND MARNER WILL
LEAFS.
AS THEY OUTCHANCE